welcome to this video against Yardbird
Grandmaster leubronn get him really off
now um yeah maybe not the Benoni is
really tricky in those positions let's
see what we get him and this is a funny
situation i'm just looking at the score
we are having in about fifty percent
nine and a half out of 19 nine wins nine
losses one draw and i'm very sure the
draw was split backing them okay taking
queen bee three this is this is i think
the the way this opening is played
nowadays but i'm not something that not
someone to consider an expert Bishop t2
probably probably Bishop a six that's
that's very a very simple continuation
it just takes everything off right okay
Bishop a 6 mm yeah that's that's really
a bit a bit lame all that is this mmm is
this how it is played looks really
inoffensive for both sides actually ok
so he might take on e2 is there some way
to I can play Bishop at three of course
yeah maybe this one just keeping the
pawn for the moment and go from them
look be one in Crowley will play look
the six like will be three okay three
yeah maybe I can do something like that
rook b3 and tending rook a 3-2 sudden
idea you can play rook t2 down I have
okay one I don't know i don't know let's
let's be quick about that I am I just
miss placing my pieces here let's think
about it for a moment a six it goes a
six
I'm not sure about that
yeah if I can just take 4 44 total
equality but I wonder if there's some
way forward look in three basics maybe I
don't really I don't really see it feels
a bit misplaced to the whole the whole
thing I I don't know let's just keep it
very very simple him and take I take off
stuff I wasn't sure Luke a three a six
might be an might be not very good at
all yeah I just intend to go to d7 or d6
activating the rook it is very dry of
course Bishop e2 I can think of just
taking on c6 yeah okay one rupee 256
also possible I can take it to ya I
thought rook d4 yeah yeah d for a 4
that's a bit different it's it's
whatever you do this is this is going to
be very draws in any case
yeah I can do whatever really take on f3
and make some some look for the King g6
or something but it sits there multiple
ways to play it's nothing terribly
forcing here maybe this is looking for
ways to get some life into the position
I thought maybe if I it was possible ok
I'm going to play ok for him look at the
upon
this is also threatening a4e form which
almost traps the bishop as some g for
trickery maybe I'm not really am
threatening you for now and threatening
the born on a seven this may be
something for me on am I too optimistic
here maybe maybe this is something
mr. maybe I'm released winning a pawn
Jack okay so it's not reacted I can can
play okay for okay they look at you I
mean sorry on e4 you can play with a
tune so what am i doing now just take
just take a seven I guess um let's see
if or wait II for look at you look
before this is still trapped you for
look at a fee for Bishop edge whatever
as possible okay so i take a seven he
might take it to where this is also also
on I can play see form C for Bishop
takes King takes maybe this one but
maybe this one try to do a little bit
i'm a bit more active still and jack now
i'm really intending to take a seven
yeah yeah i can come over with the king
I'm playing with the King here and he is
not at least not yet so I can take now
you can try for counter play with with
this with against the edge porn so um I
can go King III to cover that the
probably should tie morning so just the
a porn and go with the King his age porn
will be will be counter play
that's some good way to learn to set up
the pieces now I mean it's not really
it's not really the case that i can
think about it too much I want to stay
near near the pawns to keep it safe
check
yeah I have don't have any winning
Shaun's here I think so does not look
like it
can you force is getting I'm getting
tricky even here check that's not good
check I can I cannot believe it that
that I'm screwing this up unbelievable
stuff ah how does a plate like a total
[ __ ] I in this end game which was just
totally good for white check
unbelievable check me it does not matter
it does not really matter what an idiot
I am I mean from this emmy how can you
lose this end game i really should be
should be shot again for that stuff so i
went here and clearly I'm just I'm just
better yeah what did I do wrong yeah I
came here or not or not a five maybe I
should just get the C porn and I
probably that's also a problem I should
just get the seep on the hip all is not
doing anything that is really this is a
process the key this is the problem this
was wrong yeah I just wanted to get this
pawn pushed quickly this is much
stronger yeah that's not stronger
around here if we look at this yeah I
can try to play play this position where
at least i have a pawn but it's it's
difficult to do anything the way it
calculated oops the way I played it I
just push the pawn and this is this is
not good this is simply not good my
ruckus is tied to this pawn and check I
have I have some problems here you can
activate the king and push this f5 g4
stuff yeah and jump now I must play King
you for here for example and here I'm it
starts to it starts to get a really
really tricky if not problematic
yeah I'm just winning jeffrey r & F form
check why am i winning here because he
cannot go there he has to go here and
now look the eight wins oh no oh no
that's so sick that's so sick so here's
here simply nothing going on here this
this is why I had this I was really
wondering why am I in such big trouble
because he's playing something that he
cannot play here I'm loser here winning
with f3 and f4 not King f2 chatted stood
probably yeah II Forester okay I cannot
really do that with this time before 20
seconds I'm not technically fresh enough
to to see those things before I still at
all before I still wrong because if he
takes I'll go here and now he has a
problem is always in this checks hear me
even better and he has two he do
something like that Jack if the check so
I was only losing really in the final
stages when I had no time really
wondering why it was so bad all of a
sudden and it really didn't make much
sense to me what I showed earlier was
better to to get winning chances but I
still shouldn't lose and yeah it was
really do to me overlooking several
technical elements him that are lost the
end damn okay thanks for watching